let's jump to this story from
timcast.com
printful Cuts ties with gays against
groomers group seeks legal action
claiming defamation quote we are looking
into all of our options with our
attorney Ron Coleman and intend to
pursue legal action you ready for this
one all right gaze against groomers this
is an organization of lgbtq people who
oppose groomers anyone of any background
who targets children to groom them all
right here's the best part
printful on Sunday who produced
merchandise for the organization
suspended business with gays against
rumors to quote mitigate the risk of
being affiliated with an organization
that doesn't represent our company
values we do our best to remain neutral
and respect freedom of speech yet we
draw the line of content that foments
hatred towards any person or group reads
an email let me break that down for you
printful is ex explicitly saying on the
issue of pedophilia they are neutral and
don't want to be associated with an
organization that would disparage
pedophiles oops hey hey didn't Michael
Jordan say that groomers buy sneakers
too right
am I getting that wrong I
might be getting that wrong
trying to tighten the market on on the
guruma market it's a pretty big Market
out there especially with Balenciaga and
their marketing campaign especially with
the FBI and you know protecting Epstein
for over 30 years ditching the victims
to the side I mean hey this is a
business trying to make money here and
let's call us you know a spade a spade
here they they want groomer money and
they want to support uh well you said it
right there hold on a minute you know
imagine you make t-shirts right and you
got these really wealthy individuals
like Epstein and his clients you don't
want to lose those people you know so
printful is upset that yikes
but look
we keep giving the benefit of the doubt
whenever stories like this happen and
we're like oh they probably just assume
gays against groomer is anti-lgbtq or
something and I'm like no no you can't
do that here the organization is called
gays against groomers it's literally
like people who are lgbtq being like
pedophiles are bad and they're like
we're gonna you're inciting hatred
against them so we're gonna be neutral
on this one okay okay principal like
Luke said go hang out with Balenciaga
see how that's doing see how see how
it's working out for them I mean they
only got a yay supporting Balenciaga I
don't know anyone else is supporting
them uh serious and he made statements
in favor of them yeah recently but other
than that I mean I I think it's pretty
clear that a lot of people weren't happy
with uh the way that they handled their
marketing and I think this is pretty
obvious I mean it the organization's
name is gays against groomers and and
you're you're getting rid of their
ability to sell merchandise because you
don't agree with them their main thing
that they do is that they're pushing
against groomers against people who hurt
children you're saying we don't know
yeah we're we're neutral on that issue
they try to pretend like it's not a real
thing it is absolutely a real thing and
you've seen them try to change the
language and the narrative in Academia
right I'm sure you've heard of the
acronym NOW they use minor yes Maps
right so Oh that's oh so so they should
there's another statement they said we
suspended gays against groomers because
the underlying homophobic and
transphobic misinformation spread by
this organization does not align with
our values of respect and inclusion let
us be clear that we do not condone child
abuse or The Grooming of minors we uh we
will not work with an organization that
spreads harmful accusations against the
lgbtq plus Community under the guise of
protecting children you see what they're
doing even if you are lgbtq and you
explicitly are just like hey it's the
grooming of a problem with they accuse
you of being homophobic and transphobic
it's like yo they're literally gay
so let me show you something funny
Media Matters put out this uh thing uh
it's the retweets it mentions Media
Matters yeah right wing figures
anti-lgbtq tweets and accounts before
and after musk acquired Twitter yeah I'm
number one you can see Tim pool right up
top I have uh 20 261 retweets that
mentioned groomer Thirty one thousand
one hundred fifty three uh mentions of
the word groomer what they don't tell
you in this is that the Tweets in
question are me saying quote
groomer does not refer to lgbtq people
so I have like three tweets that got
like tens of thousands of retweets or
whatever specifically saying that they
then take it and call that anti-lgbtq
because they're lying and manipulating
and for some reason I just don't know
why Media Matters really wants people to
believe that that lgbtq people are
pedophiles now I don't know why they
would do that but let me let me let me
give you a really good example Blair
white is on the list Blair white
responded with like the clownery of me
being on this list Blair white is trans
this is absolutely insane and gaze
against groomers is number three
I just want to um
send my condolences to jack besobic for
being number two sorry Jack there's a
new game in town that's the first loser
right second place yeah that's right
jack second place is the first loser
this is but it's ridiculous
I mean the whole thing is ridiculous
that it it's literally considering the
fact that it's gays against groomers the
the they're essentially saying that
it's not about LGBT it's about the left
and we're using LGBT people uh as as a a
way to to push forward our leftist
agenda not specifically the things that
that the LGBT uh LGBT people want
because gays against groomers are
obviously LGBT and have a different
political perspective it's just that the
left is it has taken the taken on the
mantle of LGBT and anything that the
LGBT Lobby does is uh always the last
it's always associated with the left or
with the left ones you know uh I love
simulism Elon Musk was talking about
simulation theory on stage I guess when
he was getting booed or something and
I'll tell you why because because I I
kind of have to just believe I'm half
kidding by the way that when I come out
and every statement I've given on this
every video I've done explicitly is
about how groomer does not mean lgbtq
but they keep saying it does they have
to just be a bunch of like mobs
non-player characters roaming around
randomly on the hillside controlled by
no one because like I don't know how
we're at the point where I go oh the
word groomer doesn't in any way refer to
lgbtq people they just immediately go
why are you calling gay people
pedophiles and I'm like I literally just
said the opposite what are you talking
about that's where we're at right now so
it's look in all reality it's a cult but
it's hard for me to believe that even an
occult they can hear you say you know
the sky is blue and then they go this
guy's not green and you but I didn't say
it was where are you getting these ideas
from that that's where we're at right
now how you solve for that I have no
idea maybe it's not even solvable
I'm sure they've gone out and pulled it
and realized that we're on the right
side of it
and you know they're like oh we got to
stop this I mean you know
to me it's just you know you go back to
when Trump's saying fake news fake media
back 2016-15 and they were like this is
made up no we're very very on and it
turns out of course yes there is fake
news that is a real thing
are you familiar with the name Chris
saliza he got fired from CNN yeah he has
an immortal tweet a tweet that was
immortalized he one time tweeted I'm
gonna say again for the thousandth time
or whatever the the media doesn't pick a
side and it has been I I have gotten a
whole lot of mileage out of that bad boy
let me tell you I got that saved in my
phone yeah and that thing is has allowed
me to perform some fun dunks but uh it's
true like the media narrative is
unquestionably a leftist narrative
there's no more room for denying it or
arguing it the Overton window of
acceptable argument or acceptable debate
has been set by the left and anyone that
steps outside of it is looked at as you
know Untouchable and the goal of the
left is a whole cultural revolution in
the United States like are you familiar
with James Lindsay so I'm I'm totally
like I'm right on the same page with
that guy James Lindsey Chris Ruffo those
guys really have their I think they have
their finger right on the pulse of of
the real heart of the problem in the
heart of the problem is that schools
have been infiltrated by left-leaning
people that have an ideology that they
are using in education and it's the
schools of education so it's not just
your colleges your where kids are going
it's the schools that teach teachers so
these teachers that are coming out of
the schools of Education are
indoctrinated into an ideology that they
cannot even see they are unaware that
they are indoctrinated in it they are
completely unaware that they have been
taken and given a framework to look at
the world
that is like putting on racism colored
glasses or sexism colored glasses
essentially their oppression colored
glasses and all they see in the whole
world is oppression and when you teach
kids through a lens of Oppression you
you psychologically damage them because
young people should not be shown the
world as a place that is full of
Oppression even if that's the case that
you can say look there's all kinds of
different ways that people are oppressed
you don't tell seven-year-olds because
that's emotionally damages them and they
become they they lose they they get
depressed and there's all kinds of
horrible things and you're seeing in in
the the levels of depression in young
people nowadays you've got so many
people on ssris it's because of the way
that people that kids are taught in
schools and it's it's it's because of a
left leading I'll give you a great
example today today I was at a high
school given an award to a teacher that
actually cared uh who's doing a great
job in her school and I walk into the
school before I get in I walk through
the parking lot and
not really any bumper stickers on the
cars except for two of them and two of
those cars parked right next to each
other both had Bernie Sanders stickers
you know these kind of real left-wing
slogans on it and it's like seriously
what were the slogans ah I can't
remember how left wing because some
left-wing slogans are slogans like you
know everybody deserves health care and
then there are other left-wing slogans
like liberals get the bullet too yeah
yeah
it wasn't that left wing but it was you
know you got Bernie on there and then
just this last week last week I had I
think they're all that left wing at the
end of the day though is my prize my
point because it's a religion at the end
of the day so I had a uh concerned group
of parents came to me uh Wood County
West Virginia that's out in Parkersburg
and they said and this is a very
conservative County they said you won't
believe what our children have access to
they showed me this material all the
children yeah and so something actually
very very similar to this so he's
pointing to the problem actually is that
book yes I think actually look inside
it's it's got the pictures that's it
that's the one that's the book and
that's the book that they have access to
and these parents their children because
we were living in covid and all that
people have got iPads and all that and
that's how they were accessing books and
it's on the accessible reading list
through the library for elementary
school children elementary school
children have access to this I mean what
in the hell is going on here I can tell
you and this is just and this is Wood
County West Virginia Which tells you
it's probably happening at all I mean
all over the state but it's just
absolutely shocking stuff Tim did you
have something you wanted to say or did
I just want to uh I I'm pretty sure that
YouTube age restricted the project
Veritas video from the Chicago teacher
which is kind of ironic since YouTube
doesn't think it's it's okay for small
children to watch when it literally
happens to small children which is
absolutely mind-boggling well it's like
when the when the parents came in and
said I'm going to read you from this
book start reading stuff and then
they're like hey hey you can't say that
here order order if you keep talking
we'll kick you out and they're like what
you made my kids read this book yeah the
whole point of that is because it's as
much as there are people that are
worried about the LGBT issues the point
the LGBT issues in that are really a
tertiary topic the point is to have is
to make revolutionaries to make kids
that are unhappy with the way Society is
because it's the marxists call it
cultural hegemony right it's the society
remakes the society so when you have
kids that go to school that learn how to
be good Americans they go and they come
out of school and they go into jobs and
they become good Americans and they make
more kids that go to schools that learn
how to be good Americans what the left
wants to do is get into the schools and
stop making stop having those kids that
go in come out as good Americans they
want at least a portion of them to come
out as radical leftist revolutionaries
and if you get a portion of them to come
out like that all you have to do is get
you know whatever a third or ten percent
or twenty percent of the population to
be really really upset and that can
uproot the whole civil realization and
that's the goal the goal is a revolution
and anyone that tells you anything
different is lying to you yeah now I
don't know if this is in this book or
not but part of the material that
brought it's like two young guys and
here's how you satisfy your partner and
I mean literally yeah but that just
shows Discord yeah like I said what's
going on in there the sexual stuff
that's tertiary yeah right point is the
Discord the point is the fact that
they're revolutionary the point is they
don't fall into categories that you
would consider normal they that they're
they're not heading they're not
hegemonic categories they become
revolutionary there somehow uh they're
somehow subversive or whatever and if
you can subvert the whole society or if
you convert subvert a portion of the
society to the point that they will
ferment a revolution then you can uproot
capitalism right you can get rid of
capitalism you can get rid of what they
would what they would call hierarchies
that are uh uh um that are unfair
oppressive hierarchies and and the whole
intent is to throw the whole system over
and destroy it all because they think
that the system is illegitimate they
think capitalism they think that owning
property they think that that the reason
that they're against free speech is
because they don't believe that there is
Free Speech they believe that you're
only trying to use speech as a way to
exercise power right well look and I do
know people in West Virginia listen to
this we're fixing this next month in the
legislature so just hang tight
I hope you're right because this is
James Lindsay like I said I I'm
I think he's on the on on the right
track and if he is right a cultural
revolution in the United States like the
one that happened in China you know it's
going on right now and kids are
attacking their parents and you see you
know you've got videos of kids screaming
on college campuses screaming at the
teachers that's the same thing that
happened in China you see that uh woman
who was at her dad's funeral or whatever
yes attacking him horrifying but yes and
it's the exact opposite of honor thy
father and thy mother 100 yeah yeah well
I mean look in West Virginia I run
what's called The Hope Scholarship so
that's an educational savings account
and that has allowed kids to take their
and their parents their version of
taxpayer dollars and use it uh outside
of the public school system it's
educational freedom in West Virginia we
also allow families to use that for uh
homeschoolers so homeschoolers can also
take look it's their tax dollars let
them use it and educate their children
how they want to and that is a way that
we're able to get some of our kids here
in the near future away from this stuff
and get back control homeschooling is
key it's very important and millions of
Americans are starting to do this you're
right about homeschooling I hate to
throw water on what you were saying but
the the video that Veritas just put up
that's a private school yeah yeah well I
mean but this is why we have homeschool
as a part of it homeschool is important
homeschool because then they're yeah and
we have a huge homeschool population in
West Virginia and it was very
controversial particularly with the
teachers unions including homeschool
students in this but it is part of it we
also have a legislation that's under my
purview also so we got micropods uh we
have our learning pods pardon me and so
where you can get groups of homeschool
kids come together and use what's called
The Hope Scholarship their tax dollars
to be able to educate themselves free of
all of this and just parents coming
together and what used to happen in this
country in a very traditional manner uh
you know trying to get back to those
things I mean the cultural left
constantly wants to like have a
Evolution every five years of what is a
norm in this country when to me you know
a lot of people are like well I'm a
conservative it's like what are we if
you're conservative what are you trying
to conserve like there was a point
someone brought up on the show a while
ago that the the fact that our lives are
dramatically different from our
grandparents is unique to this time
period yeah for all of human history
your you and your grandparents had
basically the exact same kind of life it
was uh it was population growth was it
was stagnant your grandfather farmed you
farmed your grandfather was a blacksmith
you blacksmith you very much lived the
same life now with rapid the rapid
advancement of technology and Energy
Technologies our lives are completely
different and culturally though Tim
there there's a thing it's called
transmission right and happens through
generational things your parents have
taught you their parents taught them and
there's transmission of those Norms
values things like that that each family
has different Norms cultures and values
that they hold dear that's all been
blown up yeah right I mean to your point
this has all been destroyed and it gets
leveled out like every five years and it
gets lower and lower and lower the level
that we're at yeah to continue the
conversation about schooling I I think
there's a reason David Rockefeller
influenced our modern education system
which is really an indoctrination system
and now that he's no longer here uh with
us other individuals have kind of taken
his mantle and are also influencing
education those individuals are
individuals like Bill Gates Mark
Zuckerberg that have spent hundreds of
millions of dollars on new experimental
education that has lowered reading
levels made students uh less intelligent
as they're promoting more woke doctrines
and Equity these are literally the
policies that are being influenced right
now by a lot of very powerful
individuals setting up this education
system which is not really educating
people at all just indoctrinated them
into the woke cult yeah let me and if
you sorry just real quick though you
look at those National test scores they
are freaking abysmal they are awful I
mean it cannot get any worse well I
guess it could get worse but this is the
lowest it's been in decades it is awful
and that is I do want to point this out
if I am elected to congress if I get in
I'm going to be pushing for national
school choice just like we have in West
Virginia give people back control of
their tax dollars to be able to educate
their families homeschooler otherwise
somebody said to me the other day
wouldn't that destroy the Department of
Education I said yes exactly thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time